what did it
look like at ground zero what did it
feel like what did it smell like
what
you said it there's a sense that it was
almost like a war zone but can you paint
the picture of um how much dust is in
the air
how hot is it
how many people are there
and and again how did it feel like
it was just um
it was scene of controlled chaos control
because there was a semblance of command
and we were just trying to do our jobs
but it was such a frantic pace because
we're now digging frantically knowing
that there's life underneath this pile
and this is throughout the afternoon
this is this is
yeah i mean this was non-stop you know
uh just non-stop really for for days but
for my particular crew we literally kept
going we we initially were dispatched
over towards number seven had just gone
down
and we were searching the post office
that was there there was reports of
people trapped
and we painstakingly searched every
single inch of that building to make
sure no one was left in there and then
we were deployed to the pile
and the pile was sort of ambiguous
because it was just such a vast vast
pile i mean it went for city blocks
and we were we were assisting in the
retrieval of two port authority police
officers
were lucky enough to survive but they
were trapped they were deep down into a
crevasse and they had to be physically
dug out and extricated
so there was a couple hundred few
hundred guys involved in that process of
bringing in equipment
jaws of life airbags to lift steel you
just you know to cut pieces of steel it
was just a huge operation
and we were back toward the logistics
end of it shuttling in gear and
bringing bringing in stretchers bringing
in oxygen you know whatever whatever was
needed and you were trying to
climb over this this jagged pile of
debris it wasn't like you just walked a
hundred feet on a on a street with
something you were trying to
climb over this i-beam and then down
into this hole and i'll back up that
hole i mean just to run one piece of
equipment took a half an hour to get
100 feet 200 feet
you know mind you some of these pieces
of equipment are 100 pounds you know
generator for rehearse tools this
massive motor on a frame
unstable ground unstable ground
just just horrible conditions fires were
still burning aside you beneath you
and at one point
i kind of veered off to the side and i
was with this other fireman from my
father's old ladder company 172 and
it was strange because we were down
quite a bit down like 70 feet down into
this ravine of debris
and he says brother what do you hear
and at the time it was like dust it was
like sand just falling down a pile
and it was hissing from gas pipes and
water pipes
and and i said i hear i hear the gas
lines i hear the
sand i hear the concrete he goes no no
what else do you hear
and just the side of us was a lady's
pocketbook
and a high-heeled shoe
and someone's sneaker
with nobody with it
and i said i don't know i don't hear
anything
he says me neither he goes
no one's coming out of here
and i said no no no this there's got to
be someone coming out of here i mean
there's thousands of people in here and
they're coming out he says brother
we would hear him calling for help
they're gone
and
i still at that point thought there was
a chance and and
after about the fourth day they just
said this is a recovery now
there's no more there's no more life
there's no more chance and on our first
night we we went full tilt till my crew
my specific crew of 12 15 guys and
four in the morning we just we just
couldn't breathe anymore we couldn't see
we were caked just with it was like if
you took flour and just kept dousing
yourself
and and the lieutenant just said look
guys we're gonna go back we're gonna get
some medical aid
and then we'll come back in a few hours
and uh we we took a city bus
back through the battery tunnel
and unbeknownst to us
that morning
this off-duty firefighter stephen siller
from squad company one
he he raced down there with his pickup
and he couldn't go any further because
the traffic was stopped up because they
had a report of a bomb
so everything was held up
and he grabbed his fire gear
and he put it on stuff weighs about 60
pounds
and he ran through the tunnel
two and a half miles
got to the end of the tunnel
fire truck was coming in from the other
way
he hopped on the back
got him up to west street jumped off
tried to look for his
his company where they were
and
he was never seen again
he just ran through the tunnel ran
through the tunnel
and he he got there to help his his team
right it's all about the team so about
the guy right next to you
and he's the tunnel to towers foundation
stephen his his brother frank decided in
his name
in perpetuity he's got a fund that that
now builds a home
for every gold star family
for every seriously battle wounded
warrior
for every seriously wounded first
responder or killed in a lighting duty
first responder if they had a home
they paid a mortgage if they didn't have
a home they give them a home
and especially if it's if it's a
severely battle wounded they give them a
smart home because these poor guys come
home with no limbs
and
so the beauty of the beauty of stephen
and his selfless act
was that he's now helped
thousands and thousands of people i mean
tunnels of towers is incredible that's
part of our part of our mission is to
bring awareness to these great people at
tunnel to towers what they do they've
raised 250 million dollars to help
to help protect the protectors to rescue
the rescuers
in in a what's become unfortunately is
somewhat ungrateful society
but they will not forget
these great guys
so you uh tell steven's story he's one
of the 20 people that you talk about in
the new
iron labs 20 for 20 podcast series
if you can just linger on his story a
little longer
what does that tell you about the human
spirit that this guy
you know the tunnel couldn't couldn't
drive through so he just puts on that
heavy pack and runs
what do you make of that
that shows the depth of a man's soul
he didn't have to do that he could have
turned around and went home to his
family
and nobody would have shamed him
but
he's
one of those beautiful brave people that
take a job
and really doesn't pay a lot of money
and
you become a cop or a firefighter
or nurse or an emt or a medic or soldier
or marine airman
sailor
when you take these jobs
you you don't do it for
fanfare you definitely don't do it for
money i mean those those 13 brave souls
we lost you know week or two ago in
afghanistan
they're brand new soldiers and marines
they make 22 000 an hour
but they don't work 40 hours a week they
work 80 they work 90 hours a week so
they're making about six bucks an hour
and you know what they sign off
and firefighters and cops and medics and
emts
nurses
emergency room doctors
they don't really make a lot of money i
mean they're starting salary right now
for a new york cop i was in new york cop
for two years first
i made 12.25 an hour
back in 1989 to get shot at
during the crack wars
if you made
uh 11 an hour
with a family of four you were entitled
to welfare back then
so i was just above the welfare level
risking my life
and these are the guys that are getting
ripped up now right and and look i won't
get into any politics but like
that says something about someone's soul
that they're willing to take a job like
that and get now get zero respect so a
guy like stephen what that shows is the
depth of that man's soul and courage and
determination
it's hard to be selfless in this world
anymore
but i still know a lot of selfless
people that just just put on equipment
every day bulletproof vests fire bunker
gear
stethoscopes
you know flak jackets military helmets
and they go in and they do it smiling
that young marine
that passed
last week she was photographed and
quoted as saying i have my dream job but
she was holding on the left got any baby
and she was dead a few days later
she was so thrilled to be making seven
dollars an hour helping people right
isn't that huge like that to me says
that's a true sign of character right
there and it's important for our society
to elevate those people as heroes
you